[Music]
the Umbrella Academy finally has its own
TV show so to celebrate I thought I'd
put together everything that you need to
know before it's released on Netflix
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down all of the key information on the
group as well as the graphic novel that
is reported to inspire the first season
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you don't want to know anything then I
highly suggest that you don't off now
but for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I watch it so you don't
have to the Umbrella Academy wears its
influences on its sleeve and from the
off it's pretty clear that the boots
draw heavily from the x-men there's a
school for the gifted special powers and
it pulls a lot from the group of mutants
however the stars in the Umbrella
Academy aren't means themselves and they
are in fact a group of 43 super humans
that were given birth to by women who
mysteriously fell pregnant immaculately
Sir Reginald Hargreaves our wealthy
inventor adopts seven of these very
gifted children and at the Umbrella
Academy trains them to become
superheroes Hargreaves trains them ruff
to make them tough and puts the kids
through all kinds of punishment in order
to make them the best this has a
negative effect on the group though as
they grow up to become pretty
psychologically scarred and
dysfunctional the seven children
themselves are all equipped in different
ways and each one of them possesses a
unique skill set while Hargreaves named
them numbers from 1 to 7 they eventually
carve out their own identities and
pseudonyms so who are the heroes and
what can they do well number one or
space boy as he prefers to be called is
the leader of the team he's desperate to
please his father and goes out of his
way to do this at every opportunity
in the comics his head was grafted onto
the body of an ape and he's pretty
messed up and by far the most absurd of
the group number 2 aka the Kraken is
pretty much the Batman of the group he's
an insane fighter with a dark and
brooding personality that makes him a
real tough cookie the Kraken can also
hold his breath underwater indefinitely
hence his name number 3 also known as
the rumor is sort of the skull at which
counterpart and she can alter reality by
lying about
putting it down to brass tacks she's
definitely one of the most powerful of
the group number four is the seance and
as you'd imagine from the name this
character has the ability to communicate
with the dead he's the most morbid and
is probably what you'd call a goth to
make matters worse the character has
died before but got rejected by both
heaven and health so now he spends his
time on earth moaning about it
number five is just called number five
and his power source makes him the most
unusual five is a time traveler that is
trapped in the body of his ten-year-old
self and this show clearly focuses
around his journey to the future in
which he witnesses the apocalypse five
was the original reason that the group
split up after he mysteriously
disappeared so his return is what pulls
them back together as a solid unit
number six aka the horror had the
ability to unleash monsters that lived
under his skin
unfortunately the horror died during an
early mission by the Umbrella Academy
and not much else is known about him
last but not least is number seven who
originally had no super powers which
left her pretty much out stood by her
father she is an expert violin player
and was recruited into a grand orchestra
before becoming a supervillain and known
as the white violin so that's our cast
of characters but what role will they
take in the show and what path will
influence it well judging by the trailer
the show seems to be sticking pretty
closely to the first volume of the
Umbrella Academy called apocalypse sweet
in this we learn of the group's origin
story see them develop their powers and
the white violin rises to the forefront
there's a big twist where she betrays
them and the group end up fighting it
out with her after it's revealed that
she's now became the most powerful out
of them well it's not a sure thing that
the show will follow this exactly
it seems pretty likely and I definitely
recommend that you pick it up if you
want to know more
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the show and if you're excited for it
if you enjoyed this video then please
like it and make sure you check out my
breakdown of last week's big netflix
release Russian doll which will be
linked at the end this is a channel for
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best and
see you next time take care peace
[Music]